Well, before announcing the combination,
what is a three-man
cell
?  Teamwork will be the difference between life and death
Now,
as ninjas, you are standing at the gateway to a relationship that will last a lifetime.
Iwabe The
above 3 people are in the 5th edition
.
Hagogo
Defense Defense
Rengar Yes, the above three people are in the 25th edition Don't drag your legs nasty
Nikuba Eco
Law same kind
Itoi Tsuruhait
40th edition
I heard it
was these 6 people who got glued The
rest says that Moniwadai Fuku will come  Well, it's a
good Warner, isn't
it?
The rest of you are automatically on the same version.
Numbers given to you
Third Wave
a It's
not Nanahan,
and I'm the one in charge.